[Music]
that is team Kelly battling out to a
Taylor Swift's ready for it on the voice
tonight but get ready because team
Alicia's coming only ET online sophie
scholl AC was behind the scenes with
Alicia and her team mentor Shawn Mendes
[Laughter]
ad on Jamaica whatever she has those to
have some serious chemistry together you
can see it during rehearsals as they
prep team a Kay for tonight's battle
round it's also rashon witnessed
Alicia's total connection with her team
they come in and there and they just
like glow and they light up my team
might be the strongest I've ever had
really literally to see this time I
don't know it's just really incredible
the duo first men in Brazil performing
at the annual Rock in Rio festival where
they formed an instant bond now that
they're teaming up for the voice Alicia
and Shawn are facing off against the
other coach mentor combos Kelly Clarkson
and Hailee Steinfeld Adam Levine and
Julia Michaels and Blake Shelton and
Trace Adkins but I'm just really about
so I can see like just oh yeah me too